you've got a youtube channel it's called
a wealthy expat i've tagged it in the
title vid of this youtube video so if
you guys want to go find it if you
listen to the podcast just go to youtube
and search for a wealthy expat you'll
find it uh he's got some good content on
there i've watched a bit of it i am
subscribed to the channel as well
um can you kind of give people like the
batman origin story on how you got
interested in
this area of business because i mean
you've been doing this for how long now
well wealthy expat has been running for
one year but i've been doing it
personally for myself moving to tax-free
countries lowering taxes for about three
and a half years when i started
seriously making some money or at least
paying a tax bracket over 30 percent in
the us that's when i started looking at
a locus so
you're originally from the us
can you talk a little bit about why you
wanted to leave the us and you know how
you got into this business
for sure i'm from puerto rico which is
actually a tax-free place a lot of
americans move to puerto rico even
though i don't really recommend it it
fits for some types of individuals and
some types of families for most people
they won't enjoy living in an island and
i always learned about taxes because my
dad was an accountant in puerto rico so
he helped a lot of americans lower their
taxes down to zero percent by moving to
puerto rico and doing their tax returns
so i was always like in accounting
offices and i was always talking to
accountants and lawyers about tax so
then i started learning about
citizenship
acquisition essentially you could buy
another passport for a hundred thousand
hundred and fifty thousand dollars i
remember when i was 17 i was looking at
passports that i could buy and i wanted
to make enough money so that i could buy
another passport i wanted to be dual
citizen u.s and anything else then i
moved to the us i got a pretty good job
and i started paying about 30 35 in
taxes and then i started my business
back then which is doing just marketing
and e-commerce selling stuff on shopify
as well as helping e-commerce brands
grow by consulting them and helping them
and that's when i started paying serious
money in taxes so 40 45 tax and then i
paid my first 150 000 to the irs and
that's the moment when i thought okay
with this money i could have done
something serious maybe put a deposit on
a house maybe bought a very nice car
mercedes s-class or something so i knew
i had to do something i started
researching all over the world
and i found united arab emirates dubai
which a lot of people might have heard
they think it's this muslim
hermit kingdom which it's really not
it's a very open liberal place there are
some restrictions some laws but you can
pretty much pay zero percent tax and
there's also about 10 or 15 other places
around the world and a lot more options
that you can use to reduce your taxes
completely legally so we're not talking
about tax evasion or hiding anything or
producing forced documents it's all
legal and a lot of people start asking
me how did i lower my taxes zero and
then i started telling them and helping
them through the process and i realized
that this this could be an actual
business and the current people that are
doing this in the space
they're not that effective
to be frank so they do provide good
information on youtube but when it comes
to the actual
process behind that they help the client
it takes one year to do a process that
should take three or four months so i
wanted to take all those clients that
are usually very wealthy if you're
paying 40 50 tax it means you're making
serious money so you want the fastest
lease hassle process possible and that's
what we help them with now
and
when you move from puerto rico to the us
which state did you go to
new york one of the hottest texts okay
like did you ever think maybe it might
be better to go somewhere with a lower
tax rate like another state or it was
just like i'm
i don't have any interest in the us at
that point
it was both i mean you can lower your
tax by eight to twelve percent on the
high end if you move to a tax free state
like for example florida which a lot of
people are moving to texas which a lot
of people are moving to but it was also
i didn't want to live in the u.s and a
lot of my
beliefs in life about freedom about
being a nomad around the world exploring
many different places also about the
social laws how you talk about you know
people get absolutely destroyed when
they get divorced in the u.s and all
these rules and all these laws i started
analyzing them compared to other
countries and i found more freedom in
places that people typically think are
dumps like for example uae dubai or
countries in eastern europe which
obviously now you can't live there but a
lot of countries there or just countries
in general where i spent like one month
two months i was five months in thailand
enjoying the amazing weather so overall
i've created this life where i can pick
where i go
as a us citizen you need to be extremely
careful so that's that's what i learned
the hard way you have a us passport you
need to pay taxes no matter where you go
but if you're canadian uk australia
whatever you can pretty much just move
to another place set up a base there
face your attacks and
not have to deal with the nonsense of
your home country which is what i wanted
to get away from
i get a lot of guys that ask me about
that um idea of
you know where's a good place to live
that's friendly to fathers in case the
marriage doesn't work out so since you
brought that up um have you looked into
that with different countries are there
countries and laws that you found that
don't destroy fathers in family court if
they end up getting divorced
yeah they're typically not the usual
ones that people move to so for example
all the the big english-speaking country
like us canada australia new zealand
you're pretty much screwed a lot of
countries in the european union pretty
much could i mean it's it's 50 you can
take everything orange you can take most
most of them will be
less developed
or muslim countries so for example dubai
and the uae all you really need to pay
is like three months maintenance so if
you get divorced all you need to pay is
like three months after you get divorced
three monthly payments of like two
thousand dollars which compared to the
us you'll pay i don't know two million
if you're worth four here you pay six
thousand dollars and you're gone and a
lot of countries in eastern europe as
well that's why people typically look to
get like a russian wife because you
can't really
it'd be screwed in that way by a russian
is there also a division of assets in
arab countries like uae or dubai where
you have to split your assets with your
ex
no it's more of analysis of whose assets
whose assets are whose and then those
people maintain those assets at the end
i see okay um
let's talk about puerto rico for a
little bit because
i've mentioned puerto rico before uh
they have these acts act 20 22 i think
they're called um we have at least one
member of the community that's that's
moved from mainland united states to
puerto rico to take advantage of the
tax benefits because he was in crypto um
can you talk a little bit about like the
actual experience the state of living in
puerto rico because i've heard like
horror stories from people say things
like
electricity isn't reliable the road
infrastructure is difficult uh if you
don't speak spanish it's it's it's
harder to move around sort of thing like
what's the reality of the average guy
that's like oh i i can move to puerto
rico it's very easy and take advantage
of tax savings especially on
crypto you nailed it you pretty much
nailed it those are the biggest cons of
puerto rico i would say the crime is
quite high compared to the us depends
where you're coming from so for example
new york right now the crime has
absolutely exploded like 200 percent
increase over the last couple of months
and because of this whole situation
happening so it now compared to puerto
rico puerto rico isn't that bad compared
to new york compared to these other
places but definitely the crime is a
problem i was always scared when i was
little about somebody breaking into my
house there's a lot of addiction and
overall homelessness which is also a
huge problem but i would say it's hard
to adapt because you're decreasing your
quality of life significantly a lot of
people they move to puerto rico and
they're super happy with it they're
super happy with the beaches they're
happy with the people that are much more
they have
a better vibe and a better life so for
example people start dancing salsa on
the streets and they have more of a life
to them than people in the u.s would
depending on where you're coming from
but yes the infrastructure is less the
wi-fi is slower and it does go out every
couple of hours sometimes the
electricity can be gone for one or two
days during the hurricane the
electricity was gone for months
and yes a lot of people speak spanish
they don't actually speak english even
though it's a u.s territory so
i would say if you're okay with living
in an island that is not as developed as
the united states that you might need to
deal with some electricity some wi-fi
problems you might need to deal with
people that are less educated than in
the united states that's definitely
something i would say puerto rican
people are not as educated
if you are okay with all of that because
it means that you say 50 tax while
maintaining
u.s citizenship then go for it because
puerto rico is really the only option of
a u.s citizen to pay zero percent tax
legally
let's say you say five ten million
dollars
the only other option is to renounce u.s
citizenship so if you want to keep that
passport puerto rico makes a ton of
sense
if you don't care about keeping the
passport and you're worth 10 million
dollars you could even buy another
passport like malta malta is a million
dollars part of the european union has
access to the united states so if you
want to get access to the u.s you can
buy malta renounce your citizenship and
now you pay zero tax plus you can go to
the us whenever you want so it depends
on the level of net worth yeah i had a
friend in um california and
you know california is right it's it's
difficult state um you know if you want
to pay lower taxes and you want freedoms
but um yeah he had this idea that he'd
pick up and move the family to puerto
rico and he didn't know that much about
it so he went there with his wife and
checked it out and two weeks later he
came back he's like yeah i'm not going
to live there
so i finally you know i found that
interesting because there's always these
you know like notions and ideas the
grass is greener on the other side of
the fence and then you don't always find
that that's true um do you get that
sometimes with your clients where they
you know make a move to another country
and they're like ah this isn't for me i
need to go somewhere else
yes that's why i also advocate on giving
up your tax residence wherever you are
so for example let's say you're in
canada and you want to move to dubai
canada is pretty aggressive the cra will
try to tax you will try to do a
disposition tax basically an exit tax
when you leave the country so they'll
try to tax every single bid that they
can
once you're out of the canadian tax
system if you do it with a proper lawyer
and proper accountant then you can
structure your time however you want so
you could spend for example six months a
year in dubai let's say because you want
to be there for zero tax and the other
six months you could travel all around
the world or you could go to for example
a country like malaysia that only taxes
income sourced in malaysia it's a
territorial based tax system so you
essentially don't pay any taxes if your
money comes from outside of malaysia so
there's different options i've had
clients that for example have moved to
dubai have moved to singapore and
they're not happy
but they can also change to another
country as long as they don't go back to
their home country like canada they go
back to canada again or at any point
they buy a home in canada or they create
let's say assets or invest in a fund in
canada that could put them as tax
resident but yes i've had that
situation happen
happen but there's always solutions to
it or
you could have your setup in one country
you're set up in the uae and then spend
your time between other countries as
long
as you give up absolutely everything in
your home country so i've had for
example clients from australia that give
up their tax residence sell everything
close their bank accounts bring their
family do absolutely everything they
need to just completely get out of
australia the only thing tying them is
their passport they live one two months
a year in dubai and the other couple of
months or the other rest of the year
they live in other countries that don't
tax them and they never go back to
australia that's also an option as long
as you
okay hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you